c'est l'histoire d'un bateau tout neuf
qui devait coûter 170 millions de
contribuables québécois
mais ce traversier l'un est en train de
devenir un cauchemar pour la société des
traversiers du québec
tout ce qu'on peut nous dire pour
l'instant c'est que le f à gauthier est
inutilisable
l'info gauthier fait la liaison entre
baie comeau godbout sur la côte-nord et
matin en gaspésie pour les gens vers du
québec c'est un traversier archi
important notamment pour l'économie
locale
mais voici pourquoi ça concerne tout le
monde
[Musique]
ça fait maintenant neuf mois que le
traversier n'avance plus parce que ces
immenses propulseurs sont brisées mais
même avant la société des traversiers au
12 défendre à plusieurs reprises parce
qu'on a constaté plus de 200 brille pas
toujours très grave mais quand même ça
pose des questions sur la qualité de ce
bateau là qu'est ce qui se passe
le fbi a été construit sur un chantier
naval en italie et pour la première fois
d'anciens employés de la société des
traversiers qui étaient là aux chances
de construction ont accepté de parler à
la caméra et de nous dévoiler des
informations troublantes
on est allé à leur rencontre
lui c'est rené le brun et le plus de 40
ans d'expérience dans le domaine naval
dont 17 à la société des traversiers
elles m'ont dit que si je divulguais des
informations dans les médias
j'étais passible de poursuites au civil
et lui c'est martin saint pierre pendant
plus de quinze ans c'était lui le
capitaine du bateau qui faisait la
liaison entre matane baie-comeau et
godbout
oui les jambes retrouvera justin de tous
qu'ils étaient payés par l'argent des
contribuables
ils ont vu des défauts en cours de
construction qui selon eux avec la
qualité du traversier
c'est à dire qu'il y avait des manques
gaiement qu'au niveau de supervision il
ya eu beaucoup de problèmes au niveau
des soudures
il ya eu énormément de problèmes au
niveau des aliments des éléments de
construction
prenez le brun a même constaté qu ont
installé des équipements rouillé comme
ceux ci à bord du bateau la peinture
c'est super important pour un navire et
rené le bras était pas du tout rassuré
de ce qu'il a vu en italie une rechute
est affecté par les procédures de
peinture qui était défini le navire
maintenant rouille prématurément partout
et ça va aller en s'aggravant
j'entrevois que d'ici 4-5 ans sénateur
va coûter une fortune en partenariat
le collègue
saint-pierre de monsieur legrand a même
sonné la lame pour dire que le moteur
était mal installés c'est quand même
important
les moteurs principaux et s'est pas
tourné le breuil nous a aussi dit qu au
moment où on a mis le bateau à l'eau la
structure était pas complètement soudé
ce qui peut entraîner des problèmes
majeurs on avait constaté on avait
signalé aux chargés de projet que qui
naquit n'a pas donné suite que la
structure qui devrait s ou des ne
l'était pas au complètement maintenant
deux chiffres importants
le projet de construction d'une faq
gauthier ont coûté 170 millions au
départ mais en raison des réparations
des avions et des bateaux qu'on a dû
louer et même acheter on est rendu à 60
millions de dollars supplémentaires et
le compteur dont toujours
[Musique]
savez vous ce qui est arrivé à rené
lebrun peu de temps après qu'il a
dénoncé les problèmes de construction
sur le bateau il a été congédié pour
insubordination
martin st pierre lui s'est fait taper
sur les doigts pour une drôle raison les
toilettes
oui j'ai été reproché sur des petits
détails là l'utilisation des toilettes
pas la bonne place où ils voulaient
genre de choses-là soulevait beaucoup de
problèmes puis il ya le boscolo
important de dire que les problèmes que
dénonce me saint-pierre et monsieur
lebron n'ont pas de lien direct avec le
bris des propulseurs qui forcent l'arrêt
du traversier en ce moment mais à la
lumière de leurs témoignages
on peut se poser de sérieuses questions
sur la qualité générale de ce navire
on ne parlait avec le nouveau pdg de la
société des traversiers et il a admis
qu'il y avait un problème quand je
regarde le niveau de durabilité
on pourrait espérer de certaines de ses
pièces non
ce n'est pas au rendez vous c'est un
aveu qui contraste avec la ligne
officielle jusqu'à présent la société
des traversiers qui disait que c'était
une question de rodage et que tout était
normal
mais malgré tous les déboires des fagots
dit le nouveau pdg veut être rassurant
on va vous retournez navire en bonne
forme avant le début de l'hiver on
navire qui est sécuritaire et fiable
vous voulez en savoir davantage sur
cette histoire
regardez enquête on est maintenant sur
tou.tv pas et sur youtube
[Musique]